New Jersey boy is spreading goodwill
with Christmas with his Christmas wish
that surprised his family and even Santa
Claus eight year old Michael Bell is a
regular visitor to the hospital because
of a genetic disorder that can cause
tumors to form it appears those visits
were on his mind when he sat down with
Santa last week Michael Bell is a big
Philadelphia sports fan but this
Christmas his sights were set on
something more than Jersey is in gear
that's why he was particularly ecstatic
about this special gift from Santa just
a week earlier Michael revealed his wish
during a visit with Saint Nick who
pulled his mother Amy aside he wants to
tell me what Michael asked for if he
could borrow some money for kids with
cancer I was expecting this for evil
stuff Michael takes routine trips to the
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia for
screenings and has met several kids
affected by cancer but his mom never
thought he understood the gravity of
their situation you're just sitting
there lonely and poorly word quickly
spread among friends and family about
Michael's request and come Christmas Day
I thought I was all done then I looked
to the platform and I saw something
under the platform I took it out and
there was a million hundred dollars not
quite that much Santa left Michael Bell
$1,200 to help kids with cancer but his
reaction was priceless
it's a Christmas miracle Amy Bell says
she hopes others will carry with them
the adults can learn a lot from an 8
year old being selfless
Santa's note2 Michael red you are truly
a shining star I'm so proud of you for
thinking of others during this time of
year Michael's mom says the family's
planning to present the donation to one
of the doctors in the Children's
Hospital neuro-oncology unit where he
gets tested that incredible yeah mom was
right adults can learn from those kids
absolutely